washington journal continues
and we're back with cornell weston tavis
smiley cornell west african american
studies professor at princeton
university tavis smiley co-host of
smiling west radio show as is cornell
west and pbs television host thank you
both for being here thank you uh to talk
about this poverty tour mr smiley let me
turn to you
and ask you i understand you came up
with the idea what's the purpose uh
simply put to highlight the plight of
the poor in this country i believe it is
the telling of truth that allows
suffering to speak and if nobody tells
the truth greta about the suffering of
everyday people then they end up being
rendered invisible and the worst thing
you can do for any human being is to not
acknowledge them
to to render them invisible to act like
they don't exist and in this country the
poor are more and more a disposable
group they're more and more uh throw
away
a group
and so with with the ranks of the poor
increasing so dramatically now more than
ever there ought to be a focus on
eradicating poverty in this country this
debt ceiling plan that we've just agreed
to in here in washington uh that did not
extend unemployment benefits didn't
close a single corporate loophole didn't
raise one cent of new tax revenue on the
rich or the lucky so the corporations
walk away scot-free again the banks get
away
wall street gets away once again and so
all of these cuts ostensibly are going
to be on the backs of everyday people
there's got to be a conversation in this
country about the poor they do matter
and the white house needs to understand
that and the republicans in congress
need to understand that so we're trying
to dramatize that in this tour that's
taking us all across the country to talk
to people of our races colors creeds and
political affiliations and what we're
hearing is both inspiring and depressing
at the same time so where are you going
i understand you were in chicago over
the weekend but where do you go next we
started at if i might say we started we
started as i think we should have this
is dr west's suggestion we started as we
should have with our native american
brothers and sisters the native
americans are so often left out of these
conversations and in a very real way
given how we have and continue to
maltreat them them
they end up living in depression-era
recession area
era
lifestyles most of the time anyway so we
started out on native american
reservation
we went to uh to eau claire wisconsin to
talk to the hmong farmers we went into
madison to talk to people who have an
organization called take back the land
and they are arguing greta that housing
is a human right and why not put people
uh in these homes that are sitting
vacant because of foreclosure and
bankruptcy etc why not put americans who
don't have places to stay in those homes
to your point we did go into chicago
over 2 000 people in a monsoon not a
rainstorm a monsoon came through chicago
greta over 2 000 folk packed into a town
hall meeting to talk to us about these
issues and that was fascinating and that
was the piece you saw in reference in
the washington post yesterday went on to
detroit you can't talk about poverty
these days and not talk about detroit uh
where unemployment is you know just off
the charts as it were i had a good
conversation in detroit had some tension
in detroit not everybody agrees uh with
us some people think that we are
anti-obama because we're raising these
issues and nothing can be farther from
the truth uh and now here we in
washington here in washington last night
we spent all night uh on the streets
ourselves with people who are street
people we want to get a sense of what
they're dealing with and how many of
them got there and hear these stories of
women
a woman who's about to have a baby any
day nine months pregnant uh to hear
those stories on the streets of
washington last night with the capital
dome in our view the white house just
blocks away uh to be up all night doing
that was interesting for us and here we
are today talking to you about it dr
west
from your experience last night up all
night
what struck you about what you heard
well i think what we find among poor
white black brown yellow and red is the
tremendous sense of resiliency of poor
people see tablets and i
were part of the legacy of martin luther
king jr and dorothy day and the great
rabbi abraham joshua heschel that said
that poor people
are as precious and priceless
as anybody rich middle class working
class and what we have discovered is
that they are struggling they are
suffering but they're fighting back and
this tour is really about fighting back
that we know that the top 400 americans
have more wealth than the bottom 150
million that's the level of wealth
inequality that is obscene we know that
children 20 of all children each one
precious
live in poverty and over 38 of black and
brown and red something has got to be
done this is a state of emergency let me
show let me throw out some other numbers
unemployment in america national 9.1
percent african americans 15.9
hispanics 11.3 whites 8.1 percent and
then if you look at median household
wealth from a span of 2005 to 2009
african-american households down 53
percent white hole white house holds
down 16 percent dr west you implied this
but is this poverty tour about race or
class or both
it's about a moral
concern for poor people which includes
class
critical of wall street oligarchs who
are greedy critical of corporate
plutocrats who are ever richest not
demonizing them but recognizing they
have they have access to billions and
billions of dollars what we've
experienced last night in other contexts
brother tavis was what
folk have nothing that's a moral
statement and it's spiritual as well
there's a poverty of spirit in the
nation that needs to be revivified so we
have a democratic awakening and
recognized we are all interested
together
right quick to dr west's point um about
the numbers you put up on the screen i
don't believe there's an economist
anywhere in this country
if they're being honest
uh even the folks who work for the
government and provide us these numbers
if they're being honest they will admit
to you that these numbers aren't the
real numbers because there's so many
people who stop looking for work we know
these are the numbers of people that we
know are looking for work and can't find
it because they told us they're looking
for work and they can't find it but all
the people who stop looking for work all
the folks who are now on the streets the
new poor in this country the new poor
greta are the former middle class and
we've discovered on this tour there are
a lot of people that are so embarrassed
so humiliated by what they're enduring
they don't even want the government to
know that they exist they don't want
their families to know that they're we
were at a tent city in michigan
ann arbor yeah yeah right
with the homeless veterans there in
akron ohio uh
all colors all cultures let me refer to
this washington post article i'm sure
you both read it yesterday it came out
in the in the washington post
because it has been talked about as
anti-obama and here is
a quote from a 26-year-old single mother
who recently found a hospital
housekeeping job after nearly a year of
unemployment saying they're not really
giving him a chance referring to
president obama and feeling like this is
piling on and then you look at the
latest polls 86 percent of blacks
expressed approval of the job obama is
doing even as
even as support for him has slipped
among other groups that's saying that
same woman you referenced if you keep
reading that article
had a job for a program that is now
defunct right that's the key a
government pro a government program part
of the stimulus that's right that is now
defunct uh and what that means with
these deficit reduction cuts that have
been approved to now i think this is a
declaration of war on the poor that's
what i think of this legislation this
new law it's a declaration of war on the
poor so she had a job in a program
that's now defunct and there are going
to be a whole lot more people like her
who feel that way not to your point good
and you're right there is this this
dichotomy and you have to nuance uh
black folk when you talk about them and
president obama black folk respect the
president we celebrate the symbolism of
his being the first african-american but
in that same article uh what 53 now 54
just over 50 percent of black people
approve of his handling of the economy
that means almost half of black folk in
this country almost half disapprove of
the president's handling of the
economist even black people support the
symbolism more than anybody else but
they want substance and the president is
going to have a difficult time getting
re-elected he may very well not get
re-elected by the margin of black
absence at the polls you have to
energize your base so finally
this tour is far from demonizing the
president it's trying to remind him of
what he said when he ran remind him that
you can't ignore your base remind him
that you have it he knows this he has it
and he's referring he's used this term
he knows there's an enthusiasm gap right
now how do you motivate your base when
they don't have jobs when they've lost
their home when they're on the street
when they don't believe that you're
moving the economy in the right
direction how do you motivate your base
we think that by addressing their
concerns you can motivate them and if
you focus on the poor focus on those you
promise to look out for there's a chance
that people will respond and we do
recognize that bush handed president
obama a catastrophe it's more than a
mess it was a catastrophe two wars
you've got financial collapse on wall
street the problem was was that
president obama chose the wrong economic
advisers you don't choose advisors come
out of wall street when it was the greed
of wall street that pushed the nation
almost off a cliff so should treasury
secretary
he should have gone a long time ago he
should have gone a long time ago you
bring in robert cutler bring in paul
krugman bring in joseph stiglitz bring
in progressive economists who have a
commitment to poor and working people
geithner in no way represents the legacy
of martin king
well let me show you this uh wall street
journal article this morning with base
restless obama toughens tone and this is
when he he's had he's had used this this
this rhetoric
behind closed doors when the cameras are
not on him when he's doing fundraisers a
couple times this week and uh trying to
cast himself as he had for months
not trying to cast himself as the
reasonable bipartisan figure ready to
compromise but rather uh focusing on
spending money to create jobs going back
to to stimulus is that enough well one
one is not enough because the stimulus
wasn't large enough in the first place
number two it never pardoned the phrase
trickled down to everyday people it
never trickled down to small business
owners of all races colors and creeds it
never trickled down to everyday people
and as we mentioned in that article from
the washington post yesterday many of
those programs are some of them have not
even phased in others are already now
defunct but the other thing is with all
due respect to the white house the
record doesn't bear out what you've just
read many issues the white house has
compromised and capitulated i saw a
story yesterday of former uh in the
white house to president clinton who are
concerned about the president's this
white house's negotiating strategy dr
west made the point yesterday if you're
in a foxhole with somebody you want
somebody who's going to fight with you
not somebody who wants to compromise his
or her way out of the foxhole my
granddad put it this way greta there's
some fights that ain't worth fighting
even if you win but there are other
fights that you have to fight even if
you lose and i think what the american
people want to see particularly the
president's base since you went to that
article about his base they want to see
that he's a fighter not a compromiser
not a capitulator but a fighter and
that's why he's toughening his tone
because even their poll numbers tell
them that the people want to see the
president fight now it is true that as
much as uh the base his base is restless
and as much as some americans might not
like him um they hate the republicans
even more they dislike congress congress
has a 14 1-4 a 14 approval rating so
i've said many times and dr weston have
debated this on our poverty to a bus as
we move around the country i've said
many times you can't beat somebody with
nobody
and and we want to push the president to
remind him of what he needs to do at the
same time i don't see that somebody yet
that can beat this president because
they they dislike republicans more than
their than they dislike president obama
so he needs a primary challenge
at least we he needs a bernie sanders
like candidate who focuses on poor and
working people so we can get beyond this
catastrophic mean-spiritedness of the
republicans and this milktoa
spinelessness of the democrats the
two-party system's in trouble
and the wall street oligarchs and the
corporate plutocrats they checkmated
both parties so they end up talking
about cutting when we need investment
education infrastructure housing and so
forth jobs and now they're talking about
jobs but it's an afterthought should
have been talking about jobs two and a
half years ago the wrong economic team
in place it's a sad sad thing but we're
talking about fight back we're talking
about bounce back poor people and
working people they're waking up and
we're going to fight back and over our
dead bodies are more poor people going
to be pushed off the cliff all right
let's hear from joan she's a democrat in
kansas city missouri you're on the air
with cornell west and tavis smiley go
ahead
thank you i am so excited that you are
here uh this i think washington journal
is the best of the best of any program i
saw you recently on piers morgan first
time i've seen you
if only either of you were president
this country would be doing just great
i agree with every word that you each
spoke and now what anyone from that what
bothers me anyone there's to a president
says appoint a committee or a task force
translated that means they don't have
one tiny clue of what they are doing
this so-called super committee uh they
won't agree on any tiny item any more
than the disastrous sickening
performance of the ham actors called
congress i mean that was so disgusting
well joan
jones let me get your take on the picks
from senate majority leader harry reid
and then i want our two guests to weigh
in as well looks like democratic
senators john kerry max baucus and patty
murray are the picks on the senate side
for democrats do you think they're going
to represent your priorities
no i do not i think they're just the
same old same old
ham actor type thing
and it's a waste of precious time they
are not free on any of the six they're
not going to agree with any of the other
sticks at all all right yeah go ahead
first first of all thank you for your
phone call for your kind words we
appreciate it to this to this uh this
committee this is what doc and i've been
talking about greta on this tour that
concerns us uh first of all because
there are no people of color in the
united states senate
all the people of color in this country
and let's be clear america is now the
most multicultural multi-racial
multi-ethnic country ever so there are
no people of color at this point at
least
on this super committee number one
number two with all due respect to those
persons on the committee john kerry is
far from broke so there's nobody on this
committee who knows anything really
about poverty that's again what this
poverty tool is all about reminding the
leaders that everyday people the middle
class is falling more and more to the
ranks of the poor every day our friend
man right other than the children's
defense the great great man right yes
they just put a report out the other day
from 2008 to 2009
more children in this country fell into
the ranks of the poor than at any point
in this country's history where data has
been collected from 2008 to 2009 more
children falling into poverty so i'm
just not convinced that with all due
respect now and i like john kerry and
others but these 12 persons on this
committee i just don't see the evidence
where poor people are going to be made a
priority all right let's hear from gary
in pittsburgh go ahead gary
yeah good morning uh thank god for
c-span and um
you know i think the big picture is um
[Music]
um
the counts on foreign relations and the
tribal commission they're controlling
both parties
and the money that's been spent in these
last four years uh his last
with these um
two candidates for an office especially
bush
brought us into wars and wars
allow people like haliburton to make
money not uh
you know during world war ii my
my dad
they had people from the army was
peeling the potatoes and
i just think that the dollars being
being weakened and we're going to be
mulled out the european union and um
they're going to have a one-world
currency and um
we're going to be the
north american union not the united
states of america
that's about all i have to say dr wesley
i think my dear brother makes a very
important point there has been a
bipartisan agreement when it comes to
expanding the military industrial
complex we always find money for wars
1.3 trillion now tied to afghanistan and
iraq and we're not even talking about
the secret war going on pakistan and the
drones that are killing innocent
civilians but also a bipartisan
agreement on the prison industrial
complex we spent 300 billion dollars
since 1980
on the prison industrial complex and
said we don't have money for jobs
education and housing and then the media
thank god for c-span doesn't focus on
what both parties agree on that is
helping undermine the democratic
processes and procedures because greed
is blinding greed is dangerous greed
will push a person or a country off a
cliff and this is in part what we're
wrestling with democracies from below
are about making people accountable this
brother real important book
accountability for all politicians but
also ourselves as persons as individuals
and that's where we're at a moment of a
state of emergency a sense of urgency
and yet we don't see it among the
politicians just five seconds greater um
since the caller raised these wars dr
king where you asked earlier i didn't
get a chance to answer your question
completely i mentioned where we have
been where we're going is memphis we're
going to atlanta uh
mississippi a number of other places
that we're headed to uh we're gonna be
in atlanta tomorrow and at ten o'clock
tomorrow dr west and i are honored uh
with members of the king family to lay
wreaths at the crips of both dr king and
coretta scott king dr king once said
about war that war is the enemy of the
poor war is the enemy of the poor he
said that about vietnam but it's also
true of iraq and afghanistan when you
consider all the money the trillions of
dollars being spent on these wars that
we need to extricate ourselves from all
of that money applied toward the
problems in this country applied toward
the poor you get dr king's point now
that war is really the enemy of the poor
that's right we'll go to baton rouge
louisiana tyrone republican
good morning how are you doing people
good morning how are you doing bro
i'm doing so good thank you dr west god
bless you though bro thank you uh miss
greta please let me say this uh
you know
the celebrity reserve you were talking
about it earlier right before the guests
came
these people
make the carlyon family look like
brownie scouts they are criminal
from the inception in 1913 under woodrow
wilson
from that time until now within less
than a decade they bankrupt this country
they created money all over the world to
create wars they want to destroy our
sovereignty and it's just a shame that
people don't really know who these
people are dr paul ron paul is trying to
get the message out there but i i admire
i miss it that mr smiley and dr west but
i wish they put it on their agenda to
try to tell the people who these people
are the rock child family the cone lou
people all right all right tyrone i
think very important
i would just recommend the great uh
william greiter's book on the federal
reserve it remains the most important
book about this institution that has no
democratic accountability but more than
that we should also acknowledge that the
federal reserve has two aims financial
stability and full unemployment you
would never know it has the second aim
because it's been dominated by oligarchs
who are concerned about inflation
rather than full
of
full employment full unemployment full
employment so full employment just drops
off we were with john conyers just
yesterday before yesterday in detroit
talking about the uh the full employment
bill
it's fundamental you would never know
the federal reserve has any concern
about it because the oligarchs have
colonized the institution it made it
obsessed with inflation so that their
profits can remain well that brings up a
point then specifically what policies
are you advocating for first of all um
you can't answer that question i can at
least without talking about the stuff
that's already been missed because a lot
of americans who believe that our best
days polls have borne this out the vast
muslim report of months ago
finds that the majority of americans
think that our best days as a nation are
behind us and you see that being born
out in more and more polling all the
time so there are a lot of americans who
think that an opportunity here has been
missed that when the president came in
with all of that wind at his back with
control of the house and the senate that
he had an opportunity now with a divided
government with a party that says no to
everything with a party that he's up
against and his obstructionists in a lot
of ways
a lot of folk who are concerned and i'm
one of them that not a whole lot can get
done not a lot is going to get done and
whatever is going to get done the
president has to so compromise and
capitulate to get it done that you
wonder what you're really getting when
you get stuff like the debt ceiling
raise with no extensive unemployment
benefits no corporate loopholes closed
no taxes on the rich and the lucky so
you
you
you pile on poor people once again uh
but the short answer your question is
jobs jobs jobs we have to have full and
full employment we have to have greta a
jobs bill now here's the problem i was
on huffington post the other day on our
poverty tour bus um just checking in and
hummington post somebody there had put
together a a a clip a sizzle reel a a
series of clips greta of all the time
since he's been elected where the
president has said now we're going to
focus on jobs and now we turn our
attention to jobs and now we're going to
focus on jobs he's saying that again now
and i think what this probably too is
all about what other americans are
saying as we're talking across the
country we hope that he's serious this
time we hope that this time there really
is a concentrated laser focus on a jobs
bill but when the president said
yesterday the day before in his
statement to the nation that we have to
have
an extension of unemployment benefits
how do you juxtapose that statement with
the legislation you just signed that
didn't extend unemployment benefits so
we just want the president to to to be
serious about this to be focused on this
and again we know what he's up against
and it's you can't say it enough times
that he's up against the party that
doesn't want him to succeed mr mcconnell
said that clearly a couple years ago his
job was to make sure that obama was a
one-term president but if the president
can get focused and rally the people
behind him around jobs i believe
something can get done all right we'll
go to fort pierce florida michael
democratic caller
yes good morning good morning yes good
morning everyone
uh
i just want to say to you two gentlemen
i have followed you for a long time but
when we talk about
martin luther king let's not forget
malcolm x yes
every now and then
because without martin i mean excuse me
without malcolm society would have did
martin luther king the same way
they're doing president obama
one more thing i like to say
vote
to those people who are listening
vote
cry today
vote tomorrow
vote you can vote yourself out of this
go into the military those of us who
who say i will not fight for the white
man go into the military care what
nobody say
take care of your country that's all i
want to say all right dr west what do
you think dear brothers absolutely right
but when you talk about my can we talk
about martin what you're really talking
about is two
persons who were willing to live and die
for what they believed in they had a
love for poor people every morning they
got up they put on their cemetery
clothes they were coughing ready for a
kingdom in which poor people and working
people had dignity could live lives of
decency what we what we missed today and
this is something that tavis and i talk
about at every stop
too many of our leaders are up for sale
in america almost everything is up for
sale everybody's up for sale it's money
money money our young people living
lives of emotional emptiness because
it's all about the benjamins we
understand money is crucial but if it's
only about money then all of us are
going to slide down the slippery slope
malcolm
martin fannie lou hamer rabbi abraham
joshua heschel there was no price they
knew there was a human value that has no
market price and we're losing that in
the country i have an email here from
carl in san antonio texas he wants to
know if we could have more available to
help our legitimate poor if we find a
way to direct funds from those
undeserving to those that are needy from
circumstances that they did not cause
i hear that um and we saw some of that
last night um i don't want to deny the
fact that some of the persons we saw on
the streets last night are substance
abusers um some of them have made bad
choices but who among us has not made a
bad choice or choices i know i'm exhibit
a i'm a witness
i call crack wrestlers oh crap a book
out right now called fail up greta that
talks about the 20 worst mistakes i've
ever made in my life in my career and
how but for the grace of god i would be
on the street i'd be unemployed i
wouldn't have a tv or radio show because
i've screwed myself so many times with
bad decisions and i can't even count
them i just narrowed them down to the
worst 20 so this book fell up he's
celebrating his 20 20 wonderful years in
broadcast but but at the end of the day
to your question though um
i just don't like this demonizing of the
poor this report that came out recently
from the conservative heritage
foundation
that tries to redefine what it means to
be poor in this country in ways that are
just laughable i saw the bit that
stephen colbert did about that uh on his
show on comedy central uh just because
you have a refrigerator and because you
have a microwave that does not make you
middle-class it doesn't make you wealthy
so this conservative pushback on what it
means to be poor is troubling for me but
i want to go back to the caller just a
second ago who said vote
dr west and i both agree with that we
are active participants in the electoral
process we vote every election but there
are a lot of people in this country who
did think
a couple years ago that they were voting
their way out of this that's the problem
a whole bunch of folks and i mean a
bunch of black folk a bunch of white
folk a bunch of independents a bunch of
reagan democrats a bunch of concern a
bunch of republicans crossed the aisle
to support uh president obama he tells
the story all the time about how
republicans would walk up to him and
whisper on the campaign trail i'm a
problem i'm a republican but i'm voting
for you and he'd always say why are you
whispering
so
the point is that a whole lot of
americans thought that they were voting
their way out of this and for many of
the persons who thought they were voting
their way out they're now deeper in here
again the new poor are the former middle
class well then dr west why not sit at
home in 2012 as a protest vote if that's
the case that tavis was just explaining
then
why not sit at home and not vote send a
message no i think people ought to ought
to participate i think people ought to
vote but when we say lift every voice
which is a great anthem of black people
you lift your voice not just by voting
sometimes you lift your voice by
moving to the streets
mass demonstration
civil disobedience you see tavis and i
are willing to get arrested we're
willing to go to jail for poor and
working people that's a lifting of a
voice which is far beyond voting but
voting is one particular expression of
your voice and again it's not confined
just to the two-party system two-party
system becoming more and more decrepit
it's so dominated by the moneyed
interest and if both parties don't wake
up we're gonna we're gonna find
ourselves in a situation in the 1850s
early 1860s when one party begins to
fade and decline and new forces begin to
emerge we don't know what form that's
going to take but my hunch is something
like that is in the making well
tavis is there lessons to be learned
from the way the tea party group
organized their efforts for 2010 yes for
your side absolutely i i i've said
countless times when people pile on the
tea party and i've certainly had my
comments critical of their strategies of
their methodologies of the racism at
times that has shown its ugly face in
their movement uh at the signs they've
held up at the threats against the
president the statements about him uh
you know there are things obviously that
they have done and strategies i get in
methodologies that i disagree with what
i celebrate about the tea party is that
they turn their angst they turn their
anger into organization and if you
cannot organize if you can't motivate if
you can't turn out your base then you
lose hence we go back to the point i
made a moment ago the democrats this
white house this campaign uh the obama
campaign in chicago has an enthusiasm
gap and the data the numbers are just
not on their side right now when it
comes to telling a story creating a
narrative that is that that can sell
let's put it this way we've gone from
hope and change
to
it could have been worse that is not a
winning campaign strategy and the reason
it could have been worse and the reason
why that's so is when obama first came
into office he should have told america
this is the reason why we almost went
off the cliff with the financial
catastrophe with the greed on wall
street we're not just going to bail
these people out if we give them any
support at all we're going to give them
tight strings and we're going to give
priority to homeowners
workers with job creation and the poor
that would have nipped in the bud the
right-wing populism because my brothers
and sisters in the tea party movement
they're right when they say the
government is corrupt it is corrupted by
moneyed interest they're right when they
say we gave in to wall street the
problem is they're right wing populace
which means they use that anger to
actually reinforce the oligarchs who got
us into trouble in the first place obama
administration could have nipped that in
the butt if they'd hit homeowners
workers and poor people so that populism
took a right-wing form and now of course
we check made it in terms of debating
over cutting when we need investment
it's a very sad story automation story
out of arizona yesterday senator john
mccain held town hall meeting in gilbert
arizona
and uh it got pretty heated according to
this newspaper the uh that especially
when a tea party supporter asked for an
apology after calling them hobbits
during the debate debt debate ceiling uh
debt ceiling debate excuse me on the on
the senate floor when senator john
mccain uh made those comments here again
my point of earlier um that when 14 of
the country approve of the job that
congress is doing we're in trouble
republicans are going to hear that
democrats are going to hear that quite
frankly republicans ought to hear that
that's right given this debt ceiling uh
deal that they forced on on the white
house or agreed to with the white house
so we're going to we're going gonna see
a lot more of that when dr west said a
moment ago that we may be seeing
something uh akin to the 1850s in the
country uh we may be seeing you ain't
got to go back that far apart in my
english we may be seeing something akin
to what's happening in london right now
if we do not do something about the
industry one percent of the people
cannot continue to own and control more
wealth than 90 of americans poor people
are only going to take this for so long
and as these cuts start to kick in and
as things get worse
um you know i'm not predicting doomsday
what i am suggesting is that there is a
restlessness as one headline you raised
earlier suggest there's a restlessness
in this country we're going to have to
do something about middle-class people
falling into poverty children falling
into poverty that restlessness that
hopelessness is going to turn it's going
to morph into something
the likes of which i don't think that's
part of the greatness of king's legacy
you take that rage and transform it into
a struggle for justice not revenge
love not hatred of
prosperity based on fairness not the
kind of negativity based on survival of
the slickest michael's a republican in
clayton new jersey you're next
uh good morning everyone good morning
how you doing
i'm doing well thank you i i think the
i'm listening to this program and i'm
thinking
the main thing that's going on in this
country you know from the white house to
the middle class and the poor that's
making so much of a
uh hatred i guess is
care
i mean there isn't a care factor we care
more about what's going on on the other
side of the world than we do in our
backyard and that's
if you go back in time a little bit to
hurricane katrina
how long did it take for those people
there to get drinking water medical
supplies
food a place to be
how long did it take for the fema
trailers to get there for those people
that's just a small example i mean
and right after that occurred i mean
there was a earthquake if i'm not
mistaken in pakistan somewhere where we
were there within 24 hours
i mean
as a middle class person and poor person
if the government in my direction if i
feel that they don't have any care
towards me why would i in any way mm-hmm
i think the republican brother is
absolutely right i mean my brother chris
hedges puts it well when he says that
the greatest good ethos which has been
dominant in the country since the 1980s
when reagan moved into office
is an attempt to kill compassion
to kill empathy to kill care or what
we're talking about kill love because
the poverty tour is a love tour
it just is what love looks like in
public we're concerned about generating
and cultivating care and its care across
the board across colors across gender
across sexual orientation and across
national boundaries we care about the
innocent civilians that those u.s drones
are killing every day it's wrong to kill
innocent people i don't care who drops
the bombs all right tavis smile here's a
tweet from connecticut liberal mom who
says obama knows he dropped the ball but
he also knows it's obama 2012 because
who the hell who the hell else can we
vote for i want to ask you do you plan
to vote for president obama i'm going to
do the same thing i did three years ago
as a member of the media the same thing
that you do every day although i don't
get a chance to do it on c-span and
you're very fortunate to do that i love
brian lam and i love love c-span
but my role on pbs my role on public
radio is one of accountability um i
don't get into endorsing candidates dr
west my friend and radio partner did 65
events for president obama so he did
endorse president that was 2008 2018
different year now
well then you'll be asked now
i know you're coming next year
so dr west did 65 events for president
obama senator obama then my role is now
is the same as it was a few years ago to
help people re-examine the assumptions
they hold about the poor in this country
to help folk expand their inventory of
ideas to use the platforms i have on
television radio the internet books
whatever to introduce americans to each
other so that we have empathy for each
other so that we don't turn nativists
but ultimately where politics are
concerned my job is to hold people
accountable so i don't i don't get
involved in the endorsing business and
as many of you know uh mr smiley hosts
the late night television talk show
tavis smiley on pbs now in its eighth
season
and co-host of the smiley west radio
show on public radio uh the the show
launched in october of 2010 and you're
celebrating 20 years in broadcasting is
that right all right all right dr west
turning to you now and you campaigned
for president obama they did yeah what
60 did you say 65 65.
because we needed to bring the age of
reagan to a close even with clinton who
signed those vicious welfare and crime
bills
but barack obama would initiate a new
age but i'm deeply disappointed in some
ways i feel betrayed especially by his
economic team that put the stress on the
oligarchs and so my final question for
any politician no matter what colors
what is your relation to the legacy of
martin king
the concern for the poor i would have
john coltrane curtis mayfield and nina
simone actually as well
and uh
right now i'm looking for that bernie
sanders-like candidates so you won't be
campaigning for president obama well at
the moment
in the primary
there's no way that i could say that i
would support him okay now if in fact in
the general election if it's michelle
bachmann catastrophic mean spiritedness
with a little whole lot of ignorance too
god bless the sister i'm not demonizing
her i'm just i think i'm telling the
truth about it uh um and if those are
the only two and there's not a
formidable third world third party
candidate then that's a different
situation we're not we're not in that
situation right now but at the moment
could i support i'm looking for a bernie
sanders-like candidate who's the closest
to the legacy of martin king all right
marie an independent in north carolina
go ahead marie
hi good morning i am so excited to talk
to both of you um i saw your repeat uh
episode last night travis with robert
kennedy jr and what a story um you were
talking about the private
the prison industrial complex i'd like
to add the private prison industrial
complex there's a prison in florida it's
the largest printing corporation in the
state
and it's taking away jobs from you know
the small local printers and my other
point is um
with regards to walmart and i think
tavis you need to drop walmart on your
as a
as a sponsor of your show first of all
they get tax breaks
from uh towns and cities to build their
stores
in those towns and cities they get tax
breaks and also walmart and procter
gamble they take out life insurance
policies on their employees and the
beneficiary is not the employee the
beneficiary is walmart procter gamble
there's a number of others that do it
and people that have buy working for
walmart they're left with
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
bills
one woman died she had a really bad
asthma situation in her life and walmart
made eighty one thousand dollars on her
all right
let me just
your two responses one i hear your
walmart critique and i hear it from time
to time from people around the country
uh and you're entitled to that i'm glad
you watched the program and i'm glad you
saw robert last night and that's always
a fascinating thing people want to watch
the program to be empowered by what i'm
trying to do every night on public
television but every now and again
somebody wants to push back on walmart
and i get that and walmart can speak for
themselves i don't work for or defend
walmart what i will say is uh that if we
were going to do it with every
television program uh every news program
that you watch every day because of
walmart
support or sponsorship then you wouldn't
have abc news nbc news cbs news you
certainly wouldn't have fox news um so
at the end of the day walmart is not a
perfect company i don't know a perfect
company and what i've tried to do in my
private conversations with mike duke the
ceo there now with lee scott the ceo
prior prior to him is to speak the truth
that i know uh to offer suggestions to
offer ideas and i can say that in my
time and there there are stories that
bear this out the unions have have
increased uh have bettered i should say
their working relationship with walmart
still a long way to go again i'm not a
spokesman for walmart what i'm
suggesting is if i were waiting for a
perfect company to be on television or
radio to try to empower people with a
different message i would i wouldn't be
celebrating 20 years i would have never
got on because there's so many imperfect
companies in this country i should say
it is we were just in west virginia
echoes robert kennedy with father starks
at the blessed john the 23rd pastoral
center wonderful catholic space dead in
in charleston west virginia and to see
brother tavis speaking his truth because
tavis is a free black man he interacts
with any institution he interacts with
any association but he has his own views
and he holds on to his own integrity two
degree to which any human being attempts
to do that my teaching at princeton i
there's a whole lot of associations with
princeton we produce ralph nader and
edward zaid reproduce donald rumsfeld
and woodrow wilson so i mean it's always
ambiguity in the legacy but if you are a
free
human being and tavis and i are jesus
loving free human being he's pentecostal
i'm baptist so we've got some
differences there but fundamentally
we're committed to
being free and when you're free
you step out on your own and say what's
in your heart and soul like the blues
men and women who helped make this
country soulful doug
have you talked to president obama about
this poverty tour either one of you will
you plan do you plan to go see him today
while you're in washington oh lord no
i've had no relations with my dear
brother and that's what three years now
or so
not at all but i pray for him every day
i pray for his protection i don't want
anybody to harm him or his precious
family tabitha and i actually pray
together in this regard i i i protect
him against the vicious right-wing
attacks
i respect him as a human being but i
want to tell the truth about him the way
i tell truth about
anybody i want to tell truth about
myself sometimes that's very painful
what about you travis um as a member
again of the of the media well we like
everybody else have a standing uh
request for the president
every so often my staff on tv and radio
because i do two radio shows and my show
of course every night on pbs so we are
constantly uh inviting the president to
be on our show i will say uh since you
asked i don't normally raise this uh but
i talked to the president i've known him
for many years as a friend
and prior to his being elected he came
on my radio programs and tv programs
with regularity um once he got elected
and my critique of him uh about holding
him accountable to various things um
didn't sit so well with him or the
people around him he has not at this
point uh come on my tv or radio programs
one time
since he been in the white house it's
the first president in my professional
career that hasn't invited me to the
white house for anything i've not been
invited to the white house for all the
things all the events they do never
invited to the white house media type
event media eventually never invited to
the white house bill o'reilly and sean
right wing brothers
getting access to it nobody i think the
president is wrong in that regard but
that's true we got roland martin and
other people who would like to have
sustained the interviews with the
president and he seems to be reluctant
but when he moves into campaign mode
it's going to be different i should
point out very quickly i'm not crying
about that i'm answering the question i
don't even raise that publicly
i answered it because you asked about it
but at the end of the day uh my
commitment is to uh justice for all
service to others and to try to exhibit
a love that will liberate people if that
takes you to the white house then so be
it if it doesn't so be it um you know i
don't i don't lose people with it all
right we'll go to the republican line
again allen in scottsdale arizona
um well to my black brothers i have to
say uh you know we're we're all looking
for
our politicians to have uh
what we call a kennedy moment you know
where
uh we're talking about solutions you
know
and they're missing it and here's what i
want to say to you greta there's two
things i want to talk about racism and
energy if we could get energy the
kennedy moment to come through
and have this country get gasoline below
a dollar a gallon what do you think that
does to the cost of living for everybody
across the board we become
the
number one country in the world when it
comes to energy costs secondly when it
comes to racism
please i want to say something to you
i'm a tea party member i'm a white man
okay
i love my black black brothers i don't
know where i would be in this country
without my black brothers and let me say
that that's beautiful that's beautiful
though bro
let me say let me say this this is so
important
there is no
racism in the nba
show me the racism in the nfl
the other thing is i grew up in the 60s
when it comes to uh motown and soul
train i watched all those programs i
mean i was involved i was involved with
music
look what the black people brought to
this country when it came to music there
was not one white person
that i know of that said i'm turning
that [ __ ] off you know
i'm not going to be for um aretha
franklin or any any of my black brothers
uh you know you know
so alan allen can i jump in at this
point
what's your point can we get to that
because you mentioned the nfl and the
nba
the level of racism in this country
isn't what it is it's so miniscule
greta
it is so minuscule we we need to get
people who are solution oriented all
right let's take your point doctor
he makes a very important term with
regard to cultural contribution i mean
america's contribution to world
civilization is really uh jazz and blues
on the one hand and walt whitman then
muriel rook kaiser and stephen sondheim
and mark twain and tony morrison
in the literary form and all of them
have to do with acknowledging the
dignity of everyday people those slides
don't call everyday people and he's
right in terms of the ways in which
black cultural contributions has helped
me have humanized
american society but when he talks about
racism being minuscule i think my dear
tea party brother won't spend a little
time with us and you can see some of the
effects and consequences of the
or spend some time with barack obama in
the white house yeah in terms of the
vicious attacks
but it's true that racism is less now
than it was before but before it was so
thick you talk about jim crow and jane
crow american terrorism lynching black
people and so forth and so on you see so
that we we've come a long way but i mean
we still got along just 10 seconds since
he specifically mentioned the nba in the
nfl i don't play in either obviously i'm
not that gifted but i will tell you
we're going to see how much racism
exists in the nba with how these talks
turn out with the players who've now
been locked out there's only one
african-american in the country who owns
an nba franchise the majority of folk
who play are brothers but the majority
of the folk who own the teams other than
michael jordan and the charlotte bobcats
are white so that's the first issue
with regard to the nfl we just saw what
they endured we saw what they were up
against with an overwhelming number of
african-american players and yes we've
seen over the years an increase in the
number of coaches but the coaches in the
nfl versus the players there's such a
huge gap between they will use you on
the field to win the game but as general
managers as owners as head coaches
yeah yeah i think you get my point you
know one sign of hope is the naming of
the new poet laureate our dear brother
philip philip levine
because he is a powerful poet concerned
about the dignity of everyday people his
critiques of racism coming out of
detroit we were just there in detroit
wrestling with this issue
uh and you know also the brother's
question about energy brother will uh
allen
in milwaukee growing power yes growing
power you're just trying to with van
jones and others green jobs i mean it's
uh but i mean the arts are very
important here and phil i think philip
uh levine is a wonderful wonderful uh
choice to try to tell the truth his book
what work what work is i highly
recommend we have only a couple minutes
left i'm gonna try to squeeze in one
last phone call here yvonne is a
democrat in detroit michigan go ahead
good morning um first i wanted to say
that the president has no power
apparently there are people behind the
scenes who tell him what to do
it doesn't take a ged to run the country
if george bush could do it
number two my question is why why do we
vote when the tabulations or the results
have been or can be tampered with and
dte the electric company in detroit has
the rate so high the people there are
lots of like maybe half of the city are
living without lights and gas
because they can't afford to pay their
bills all right all right that brings us
back to uh the poverty tour and the poor
tour and i'll just have you both give us
your final thoughts
my mind is she put a lot out there but
that was a democratic line yep right and
that makes the point i want to make that
there is a frustration in this country
uh even among the president's base um
and beyond about where this country is
headed this cannot be the moment where
americans think that our best days are
behind us not in front of us and people
give up there's got to be a way to
re-energize to re-excite people about
the future of this country i think the
way you do that is by focusing on the
poor let's face it the overwhelming
majority of folk in this country are
much less rich than that one percent we
talked about before if you can respond
to the needs of everyday people you can
bring the hope back
and i would say we were just in detroit
city hall there's no doubt that our dear
sister the distinguished councilwoman
watson makes a difference so voting does
make a difference but in the end we're
calling for revolution and priorities a
revolution in values a transfer of
wealth from oligarchs to everyday people
that's what martin died for a revolution
in priorities we got to transform our
society in such a way that our young
people believe it's much more important
to find joy in serving others than
pleasure in having a body stimulated
manipulated with corporate profits
corporate profiteers dr cornell west and
tavis smiley thank you both for being
here and talking to our viewers thank
you
coming up we're going to turn back to
our question that we asked all of you
the federal reserve yesterday decided to
keep interest rates near zero for two
years so we'll go back to that question
get your perspective and then in about
40 minutes or so we're going to continue
our series this week looking at the
american workforce today we're focusing
on the public-private partnership so
we'll talk about that in about 45
minutes but first news update from
c-span radio
well yesterday's decision by the federal
reserve to keep u.s interest rates
extremely low into 2013 is helping to
boost stocks around the world european
markets have opened with gains while
asian markets closed higher today
meanwhile the european central bank is
acting to stabilize the continent's
banking system by handing out more than
71 billion dollars to 114 banks that are
asking for help
and french president nicolas sarkozy is
interrupting his riviera vacation to
hold an emergency meeting with top
advisors on the financial markets and
he's pledging to stick to deficit
cutting goals amid concerns that france
could be the next triple a rated economy
to see its credit rating cut
here in the states investors are looking
forward today to new figures on
wholesale trade from the commerce
department also due the labor department
releases monthly job opening figures
ahead of the bell dow futures are down
over 100 points those are some of the
latest headlines on c-span radio